ce buste acquis
rik deville elle en 1904
12 est l'une des nombreuses éditions
pour le commerce réalisée par là
carpo la maison sus voir d'autres
fondeurs anonyme il témoigne du succès
de la négresse sculpture liés à la
création de l'afrique l'une des figures
allégoriques représentant les quatre
parties du monde
conçu par carpeaux pour la fontaine de
l'observatoire à paris à partir de 1868
cette oeuvre est réalisé à partir de
l'étude d'un modèle vivant ce qui
l'inscrit dans le courant de la
sculpture est nos graphiques la beauté
et la force expressive du visage de la
jeune femme semble mise au service de la
conviction abolitionniste du sculpteur
qui nous est révélée par l'inscription
sur le pied douche pourquoi naître
esclaves au 19e siècle l'écrivain
français théophile gautier est sensible
à l'émotion que suscite en lui cette
sculpture il écrit
l'allégresse avec la corde qui lui
attache les bras au dos et lui froisse
le saint lèbes au ciel la seule chose
que de libre l'esclave le regard regarde
désespoir et de muets reproche appels
inutiles à la justification protestation
morne contre l'écrasement de la destinée
c'est un morceau d'une rare vigueur ou
l'exactitude est née graphique est
dramatisée par un profond sentiment de
douleur